et oui marie c'est presque une chasse au
trésor qui s'organise depuis quelques
semaines dans les boutiques et
supermarchés d'ailleurs moi aussi je
pars à la recherche de mon pot de
moutarde pour mon barbecue du ce
week-end allez c'est parti
[Musique]
à l'om c'est bon vous avez votre peau du
talent oui j'ai eu mon pot de moutarde
voilà donc on trouve au coeur de la
moutarde à dijon nous avons de la chance
un apport impôts la pop art est
rationnée c'est un chien on est
rationnée malheureusement des doubles de
région parisienne côté de saint germain
en laye et on a choisi la destination de
vacances expressément pour aller
chercher de la moutarde à dijon ah bon
vous êtes venu en vacances ici par le
moutard tellement exactement et après
pour les vins pour les ventes d'organes
on propose une trentaine de saveur mais
ce qu'il faut pour satisfaire le plus de
monde possible vous si les contenants
fait qui manque c'est ça exactement deux
cartons de verre de cartons de plastique
d'emballage donc on essaye de faire au
mieux
merci beaucoup merci bien voir madame
voit la première boutique à dijon et on
a de la moutarde aller en poursuit
[Musique]
allez on arrive à notre deuxième
boutique est en fait déjà à l'entrée il
ya des panneaux qui indiquent qu'il peut
y avoir des pénuries de moutarde moi je
vais rentrer voir ça et vous vous
m'entendez ici a tout de suite
je ressors également avec mon pot de
moutarde ici aussi c'est rationner 500
grammes par foyer est ce que me disait
la responsable c'est qu'ils ont beaucoup
de monde en ce moment surtout la
clientèle qui vient des grandes surfaces
dans ce magasin les rayons sont vides
mais on trouve quand même de la moutarde
qui vient de pologne
vous allez voir
bilan des courses et bien deux pots de
moutarde seulement pour mon barbecue de
ce week end achetés dans des boutiques
spécialisées en revanche dans les
grandes surfaces et bien il est
difficile de trouver de la moutarde et
magasins sont livrés au compte gouttes
et conséquences de cette rareté et bien
c'est des prix qui augmentent 13 4% en
plus rien que le mois dernier